und in brandenburg an der havel begrüße
ich mehr mit timer güler rechtsanwalt
und ehemalige vertreter der nebenklage
im nsu prozess guten tag herr müller
würden morgen zehn jahre sind also
vergangen seit bekanntwerden der nsu
mord serie welche gefühle löst dieser
jahrestag bei ihnen heute aus
die fülle der charme haben darüber
dass auch ich den vielen menschen
gehörte die damals den opferangehörigen
nicht zugehört haben die nicht so wie
dadurch waren die nicht auf die straße
gegangen sind aber auch wut darüber dass
viele bei aufklärung gesprochen wurde
aber viel aufklärung hinter 7 wurde und
so das versprechen an die überlebenden
an die angehörigen gebrochen wurde die
sich einfach
auskunft darüber erhofft haben warum der
vater der bruder der sohn ermordet wurde
in der tat ist ja die liste der offenen
fragen wirklich lang warum wurden
wichtige akten vernichtet inwieweit
waren auch die ermittlungsbehörden in
den nsu komplexe verstrickt hatten die
täter finanzielle unterstützung warum
ist es an einem fünfjährigen
strafprozess und den insgesamt 13
untersuchungsausschüssen nicht gelungen
all das aufzuklären
ja weil es am ende des tages am
politischen willen fehlte ja wir haben
zwar aufklärungen bekommen mit blick auf
die angeklagten ja ich glaube dass die
tat der angeklagten die schulter gut
nachgewiesen wurde aber immer dann immer
dann wenn es ans eingemachte gegen die
rolle von verfassungsschutz mitarbeiter
in die rolle von geheimdiensten
überhaupt also immer dann wo auch das an
denen der bund über deutschland der welt
auf dem spiel stand wurde der start in
seinem aufklärungswillen der sehr
schnell sehr lasch und das wird sich
rächen das wird sich rächen weil hier
eine wunde geschlagen bild wurde die
nicht verheilen will und genau so wie
wir heute 41 jahre nach dem oktoberfest
attentat in münchen noch immer über die
offene fragen dort sprechen werde mir
befürchte ich in 20 30 jahren und auch
mit dem industriekomplex beschäftigen
und gibt es am heutigen jahres
tatsächlich zahlreiche forderungen nach
umfassender aufarbeitung auch nach
konsequenzen für die sicherheitsbehörden
amnesty zum beispiel kritisiert es gäbe
kaum verbesserungen bei der polizei die
ähnliche taten künftig verhindern
könnten teilen sie diese einschätzung
wenn ich wenig schwarzen schwarz malen
ja wir haben positive entwicklungen wie
zum beispiel dass die bundesanwaltschaft
früher und entschlossener anklagt ja
gruppe freitag ortszeit das oberland
glichen dresden und das olg in münchen
haben da sehr sehr klare und wie ich
meine richtige urteile gefällt aber im
polizeialltag hat sich zu wenig
verändert wenn überhaupt
rassismus ins netz das ist muss das sind
themen die immer noch virulent sind
racial profiling ist ein phänomen das
wir jeden tag in deutschland erleben
aber weil diejenigen die es erleben eben
die sind die man nicht zur gesellschaft
zugehörig zählt ja die dunkelhäutigen
die geflüchteten die muslime menschen
die anders sind kann offenbar die
politik damit ganz gut leben ja das eben
ein teil des landes das gefühl hat
strukturell im nachteil zu sein wenn sie
vom polizeialltag sprechen ganz konkret
was müsste sich denn bei der polizei
auch in den sicherheitsbehörden
strukturell ändern damit sich auch die
menschen die sie ja im prozess der
nebenkläger vertreten haben ja sich vor
rassistischer gewalt geschützt und
geschützt vielen füllen dürfen auch
durch die polizei
auf der einen seite brauchen wir eine
überprüfung unserer gesetze so eine art
menschenrechts tüv wir haben gesetze wie
beispielweise § 22 bundespolizei gesetzt
die rachel profiling tür und tor öffnen
auf der anderen seite müssen wir genauer
hinschauen wir eigentlich polizeibeamter
wird wir müssen hinschauen dass das sage
ich als ehemaliger polizeiausbilder dass
das thema grund menschenrechte nicht nur
am anfang des studiums einmal behandelt
wird sondern ford gehend behandelt wird
genauso wie beamtinnen und beamte zum
schießtraining müssen alle zwei drei
jahre müssen sie zu einem menschenrechts
training und schließlich und endlich wir
brauchen keine nazis und keine rassisten
in uniform im polizeidienst wir müssen
wege finden wie man diese person
schneller entlassen kann und ich glaube
dass wir da an der stelle auch einfach
führung in den behörden brauchen
die klare kante zeigen kleines beispiel
wir haben jetzt erfahren diese woche das
polizeibeamtinnen und beamte aus berlin
ist total witzig fanden
touren übung sport übungen zu machen im
stelenfeld dem mahnmal zur erinnerung an
die ermordeten juden europas das ist
monate her jetzt erfährt die
öffentlichkeit und baskisch zufall davon
das geht so nicht dadurch mit misstrauen
gegen den gesamten polizeiapparat
gestreut wenn nämlich das gefühl
entsteht hier sachen laufen drachen
schief uli werden unter verschluss
gehalten so gut es geht und schließlich
endlich wir können nicht jede woche eine
neue nazizeit gruppe war der polizei
oder bei der bundeswehr entdecken und
anschließend immer noch von einzelfällen
sprechen wir brauchen eine vernünftige
studie die diesen dingen nachgehen ich
glaube fest an den an diesem land ich
glaube fest an den rechtsstaat hier aber
der rechtsstaat der muss zähne haben der
muss sich auch nach innen saubermachen
und ich hätte gedacht dass nach dem nach
dem 14 11 2010 nach der enttarnung des
nsu dieser prozess in gang kommt aber
das bis heute nicht eingetreten leider
man muss sagen auch nach der
zerschlagung des einst so ist ja rechter
terror immer noch eine reale gefahr das
zeigt der mord an walter lübke das
zeigen auch die anschläge von halle und
hanau meter mal wieder danke ja für
diese auskünfte und ihre meinung an
diesem heutigen zehnten jahrestag danke
nach brandenburg an der havel
haben sie dafür interesse vielen dank